hello everybody and welcome to Episode
number 16 of my 1 hour flipping
challenge today we're going to be doing
veton drops only for 1 hour uh some of
the major drops are going to be the Ring
Of The Gods as well as the dragon
pickaxe which actually looks pretty
promising and yeah let's jump into
it okay everybody we're about to get
started we're going to be doing 1 hour
of flipping veon drops uh the main thing
going to be the dragon pickaxe and The
Ring Of The
Gods uh which be a little bit hit and
miss but let's give it a try and yeah 1
hour let's
go let's go there we go okay so I think
we're going to start with the dragon
pickaxe for sure so approximately
1820 or something we'll buy it
for okay
182k and we'll try that has a pretty big
limit on it so we'll start with five um
now ring the gods is going to be a bit
hit and miss but we'll give it a try uh
100K margin buying it for
approximately 10
for 100k or something yeah but most
recently as 830 okay we'll give it a
try 10 for
1K okay so those are going to be our
larger offers in now let's move on to
some of the smaller items Dragon twoh
hander yeah we could do some dragon two
handers we'll just calculate the margin
though because it's not too
expensive uh I did this in my weapons uh
1 hour challenge actually and they had a
pretty good margin on it but they did
buy pretty
slow um but yeah no 6K is not
bad
149 and we'll just start with 10 for now
oh we have a dragon pickaxe already
actually so pretty nice we'll pop this
in here
for uh let's try
70 18 80k
uh for now which would give us a 60k
margin which is pretty nice now the
dragon pickaxe has a 40 limit on it I'm
pretty sure uh which is quite nice okay
we sold the dragon pickaxe right away so
that's a 60k profit right
there um wow maybe we should done that a
little higher uh but yeah moving on the
next item we were going to try was the
ancient staff do 20 of these for now
okay we actually bought another Dragon
pickaxe which is pretty sweet that was
decently quick uh put in for 1880 k
again and just leave that for a bit
and 285 wow that's pretty damn good us
at
270 so that's kind
of interesting oh it's kind of been up
there all day though so we will probably
just do that anyway so
[Music]
285 and uh 10K and ask scw let's do
it and has a limit of 70 we'll just take
off a couple pretty sure the limit 70 on
this as well and yeah we got a pretty
much full offer slot we'll just wait a
bit here and uh buy some of these items
and we'll be back in a minute okay we
actually managed to sell the dragon
pickaxe for 188k uh so another 60k
profit and if you noticed we actually
bought another cup or another one of the
Dragon pickaxes uh let put in for 18 80k
so we're getting quite a nice amount of
profit from this Dragon pickaxe and the
great thing about it is it has a pretty
high limit for it uh so we're not stuck
at like eight or nine quantity uh we
could theoretically flip this pretty
much the entire episode so I'm pretty
excited for that okay we bought another
Dragon pickaxe so we'll pop that in
there for 188k as
well pop those both in there nice 188k
actively trade price still says that so
that's nice and we bought the blood
runes too I just recheck this I bet it's
dropped a bunch um but I kind of
expected that
so we bought him for 280 wow 300 that is
quite a good margin if we actually manag
to sell that yeah wow 2848 and we sold
it for $2999 that's 150k off blood runes
that is insane and we bought another
Dragon pickaxe completing the offer uh
so we'll probably uh buy some more of
those okay we actually got another
Dragon pickaxe uh so we'll claim the
money here and pop all of these in for
188k oh there we go all the blood runes
have bought that was a great flip for
real rooms have a look at that
yeah yeah I think that video actually
did come out on November 5th uh but
still might actually be better to flip
now and do 3,000 to begin with here um
we haven't bought or sold the dragon
pickaxe in a while I think we're going
to pull the ancient staffs out maybe we
do have half them but we're down to
about 40 minutes now oh actually looks
we like we sold another Dragon pickaxe
so that's another
60k um and now we have quite a bit of
money in inventory we do a little more
expensive item we just need to clear up
some spots we'll pull the Rune two
Anders um mostly because we just need
more space so 45
61 not that great but whatever still a
bit of profit 40
550 and that's a little bit of profit
not too bad though okay and we bought
another Dragon pickaxe um yeah I think
we should probably buy more of these but
we have the pretty much the margin un
lock down and and uh I'll do three how
about okay so it's been a little bit so
maybe we'll try the death Rune again cuz
last time I had a zero GP margin on it
let's have another quick look so
251 and we're going to sell it
for 245 yeah it's way better now uh so
we'll definitely do that 245 and uh 10K
runes and yeah pretty decent flip for
the runes today actually okay we
actually sold two our bot sorry two more
Dragon
pickaxes uh which great so we have four
we're selling now which is not too bad
188k um yeah this is definitely the MVP
so far the dragon pickaxe is awesome uh
these other items are kind of whatever
but yeah mainly a dragon pickaxe and
that's kind of what I thought it was
going to be from the start um but I'm
glad it ended up working out that way
802 and we can sell it
for 1760 yeah not too bad we'll try TR
some of these um one thing we haven't
really tried a lot is Magic logs uh now
it's usually because oh we another
Dragon pickaxe um because the margin's
really bad but when you have a bunch of
money it can be good to do because they
do trade a lot and it kind of adds up
after a while okay so we've checked the
margin for magic logs and something
weird is going on again look at that
that's way bigger than it should be 1165
at its regular
price and yeah it's like raised up in
just the last like hour or so ah
whatever let's just risk
it
1179 H let's just check it one more time
oh actually the ancient staff's all sold
that's nice we got about 60 70k on that
and 1167 okay wow that's even better
okay let's just sneak see if we can
sneak
through some magic logs so do
10K let's just
hope okay and we sold off all the Rune
two handers as well so that was probably
25 to 50K in profit not like a whole lot
uh dark crabs aren't buying so let pull
that out okay we actually sold another
Dragon pickaxe that's nice uh another
60k in profit sweet almost feel like we
should raise it up a bit or I don't know
I think we'll pull these death runes out
now and start selling them just in case
the margin's randomly raised up a bit
245 253 yeah that's another a great
great margin on runes actually okay and
actually looks like we bought another or
sold another Dragon pickaxe so that's
another 60k there and this is a really
nice item actually I would really highly
recommend it has a much higher limit
than most items of this kind of price
range so it's pretty useful in that
regards anyway 10 that's no do a
th000 h didn't actually have to reduce
that by one cuz the buying limit is
actually 2K or 8K I I think it's 2K
actually I've had some weird
interactions with the gr exchange
recently where I just like have a
feeling that I'm just the only person
getting this offer price like 1232 it
seems too good to be true and no one
else is buying it so but whenever I
check the margin it seems to be that
price so it's a little strange I'm kind
of uncertain about that okay so we
bought all the Death runes pretty much
anyway we'll just pull that out oh wow
we actually sold all those too nice um
yeah that's pretty decent margin for the
death runes as well okay we sold another
Dragon pickaxe that's another 60k in
profit that's quite nice okay so we sold
off the rest of the death runes actually
pretty nice profit on the death runes
let's have a quick look uh we got a 8 GP
margin so that's 80k uh drop down to
1201 okay we sold another Dragon pickaxe
uh so 60k there I'm think we just buy
more of these they're coming in pretty
quick and um let's see if get better
margin here
188k
18800 1801
sorry um we'll try buy another two of
these 7232 uh what would be profiting on
that um actually about 100K 80k not bad
and we sold another Dragon pickaxe not
bad okay we actually got one for 181k
pretty nice uh we'll pop that in for
188k so now we're getting 80 game profit
perck ax which is amazing actually it be
10K but you know ooh not that
many um but you know that's still 10K
and even in worst case scenario we sell
it back for 100 no biggie okay so only
notable change here is we actually did
sell 100 or 1K sorry of the magic logs
uh which is motivating I mean that's
good
sign uh I don't know if we're gonna sell
them by the time this episode's over
though okay so I got another phone call
accent
uh the only change is we bought another
Dragon pickaxe and we popped in there
for the sell price okay we actually sold
all the r pickaxes finally I guess I
sold one chunk while I was uh doing some
uh Magic logs we got another 700 or so
sold so I mean whatever it's slowly
selling and oh yeah we just sold a
dragon two Ander right now uh not a very
good item but you know eventually is
going to sell okay all the grime rars
actually sold uh all at once so that's a
pretty decent profit on the rars
actually too uh oh just in there so we
bought him for 7143 and sold him for
7232 uh 80k in profit always nice okay
so we sold all the dragon two Anders uh
which is good that's kind of nice and we
slly Dragon pickaxe for
186k
um I don't know that doesn't actually
tell me anything unfortunately I
probably still have the high price with
188k so I could just leave it in here or
I could lower it down I we only have 5
minutes left um I don't think any more
magic logs have bought yet or
sold but H we'll just leave it and see
what happens okay so we have sold the
magic locks
entirely uh which is pretty nice I'm
kind of happy I reduced the price I mean
maybe I would have been able to sold it
sell it for higher but at the same time
this is much more uh likely to happen
now we have one Dragon pickaxe left to
sell so I'm not sure if we're going to
get it in the last minute or two but but
uh either way we've we've gotten a
seriously good amount of profit from
this item anyway okay guys we have 30
seconds remaining uh just to recap here
the dragon pickaxe probably the most
profitable item after that I would say
the magic log giv us a 200k profit those
blood runes were really good as well the
runes nowadays have been working quite
well especially blood runes death runes
and law runes all occasionally will have
like a 10gp margin on it my God I'm
getting so many phone calls uh 3 seconds
remaining 2 seconds one there we go we
are done that stop the timer okay so
we're going to pop the dragon pickaxe in
for a insta sell price and we'll see how
much we actually manage to make ah that
really
sucks oh my
God what kind of margin is on this right
now all right well we still got over a
mil unfortunately we lost 200k at the
very end there which is a little bit
sucky but anyway let's see how much we
made in 1 hour of flipping Von drops
only we got
31.75 would have been 1.2 mil in profit
but unfortunately because of the rules
we got about 1 mil uh so again best
items by far the dragon pickaxe after
that uh blood runes
and um magic Vlog surprisingly so hope
you guys enjoyed and I'll see you guys
in the next episode
[Music]
oh